[Music]
all right
jacob is in las vegas hi jacob how are
you
uh how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
um so i'm 17 i'm turning 18 in
uh like 12 days and i'm getting a 300
000 conservatorship uh inheritance
i've been speaking with a financial
advisor edward jones
and i was wondering um you know what
should i be investing in the future and
can i like trust financial advisors and
if i'm
on the right steps towards uh expanding
my growth in the future
wow jacob is this financial advisor one
of our smart vested pros
no he's not uh no i don't know sorry
um okay so
here's the answer to your question uh
not because i'm cynical and not because
everybody's a crook
but the answer to your question is no
you can't trust anyone
because it's not their job
you've been given a really large job
for a 17 18 year old young man and it is
not their job
to manage this money it's your job their
job
should be to teach you
and your job is i don't put money in
anything i don't
understand because i am responsible for
this money
when you turn the responsibility over to
a financial advisor
that's when you're getting ready to lose
your butt young man
yeah you understand what i'm saying
yeah jacob you heard these stories of
these athletes that made 10 million
dollars and then they have nothing and
because they turn it over a financial
advisor
yeah i watch you i watch your shows
online okay so you've already heard this
story
so your job now is to catch up
very very quickly as a super
young investor you're a very very young
investor
and your job is to catch up your level
of knowledge
to where you become a competent investor
on
hundred thousand dollars but raise your
right hand dave i'm not putting money in
something
i don't understand right
right yeah and so you need to
let me give you a couple things to do
okay um okay
number one you need to talk to three
in-person three different financial
advisors
and you are interviewing them
not for their expertise but for their
ability to teach
you because whose job is it to manage
the money jacob
yours yeah you you
okay so you're going to interview three
different ones and who's going to teach
me
and walk with me and mentor me uh where
i
can make decisions about this money that
has been entrusted to
me okay so you've already got one guy
you're talking to that's great there's
nothing wrong with edward jones check
them out
jump on get a smart investor pro or two
and go interview two different ones but
i want you to meet with them in person
it's a 300 000 decision
yeah right okay now the second thing i
want you to do after you did that
is i want you to talk to three different
cpas
okay about tax issues and i want you to
begin to build
your board of directors for this 300 000
company called jacob incorporated
and these are your this is your board of
advisors
and you so you got a cpa in one corner
you got a real
you could if you're thinking about real
estate you could put a real estate
person on your board
you know they don't have to meet
together but in a sense you're building
this
this team around you
of people that know about taxes that
know about real estate that know about
insurance
that know about financial it's not one
guy or one gal
yeah i've got i got 15 of these people
speaking into my life
and this is what wealthy people do yeah
if you want to be wealthy people where
there's 300 grand this is how you're
going to do it
this is a big job for a 17 year old
anthony it really is and jacob real
quick are you going to college
um i well i plan on going into real
estate because i want to get a realtor's
license
and learn real estate because that's
what a lot of people my family did
okay cool um uh
honestly i i didn't i didn't plan on it
though i understand
it's fine totally okay so but you you
know you probably got
uh some lean years because
i got my real estate license when i
turned 18 and i did sell a house
three weeks later but it was to a guy i
went to high school with and we had both
just
graduated so i mean other than that i
don't know where you're gonna find
clients
yeah because i don't know who buys a
house from an 18 year old
not being mean or anything but you got a
credibility issue on your sales process
here that you're gonna have to work
through
you can become good at it and i'm sure
you're going to be because you're smart
and you're mature beyond your years
i think you're a stud i think you're
going to do great but you may have a
couple years that this is a tough
business
and so you're going to think that
through too what you're going to do is
your side hustle to eat with
if you're not making a house sale in
there but
listen the job is not get a financial
advisor take your hand off the wheel
you are driving the car that's for all
of you out there
very important lesson the only way
you'll end up with money at the end of
the story